it's really hard to tell the story
coherently of what happens to plastic
you know to watch the news and to look
at all the media coverage you would
think the debate about plastic waste has
already been resolved and won
but then if you actually look at the
numbers not only has the amount of
plastic that we're producing massively
increased it's going to increase again
significantly in the next 10 years
we are producing more plastic than ever
and it has to go somewhere so it's very
important to know what happens to this
stuff after we've finished using it
Tesco is a very large supermarket chain
it's the UK's largest by far it makes an
enormous amount of profit every year
I noticed at my local Tesco Superstore
that these white boxes has appeared with
a big sign on saying you know recycle
your soft Plastics here recycle your
wrappers your bags your crisp packets
your bread bags I wanted to find an
electronic way to follow this stuff so I
could be absolutely sure because it's
very difficult to track waste streams
around the world
so we've just seen a red unmarked Lorry
and we're gonna follow it for a while
and see where it goes
I assumed that
um all the waste collected by Tesco
would have a single outcome it would go
to one place it would either be buried
or it would be recycled what I
discovered was a much more complicated
picture than that it just is very
complicated very messy that's good and
bad
hi my name is kit I'm an investigative
reporter with Bloomberg most people have
no idea what happens to to their waste
once they put it in a in a in a bin or a
trash can and that's especially true of
plastic
it just goes away you know it's
collected by a van or it's deposited at
a recycling point and then it goes into
this hidden ecosystem that very few
people have oversight of it goes off to
sort of dirty smelly places to be sorted
and dealt with by someone else and you
don't think about it again but I was
fascinated to find out exactly what
happens to it and exactly where these
places are and where it goes
Tesco makes a big play of reuse as one
of its efforts to to help prevent
plastic pollution and by that they mean
that the Plastic Products they're
selling to Consumers they want to be
able to recycle them and turn them into
something else of equivalent so they
want to be able to reuse bottles and
packaging that they sell
I had I had three digital trackers
placed in in wrappers or bags and put
into the Tesco boxes which said they
were going to recycle them and then I
had to wait a few days to see where they
went
um and uh yeah they started to move uh
within three or four days of me dropping
them off and I could see them moving by
a truck
um one of them went to East London and
then sort of disappeared into what
looked like the banks of the Thames uh
it may have been lost it may have been
shaken loose I really don't know what
happened to it but the two other ones
took a pretty clear path which was to go
to these these Tesco Logistics centers
uh you know on the outskirts of London
and then they both headed for the same
port which is Harwich International and
from there
um they went quiet for a few hours and
the next time I saw them was when they
were in the Netherlands and heading east
[Music]
there are some kinds of plastic that are
relatively easy to recycle and those can
be sold on the open market profitably
things like clear plastic bottles are
made from something called pet and
that's good recycling material you can
reuse that over and over again clear
plastic wrap as long as it doesn't have
a label or colorants or you know heat
retardants in it is good recycling
material you can you can melt that down
and reprocess it but as anyone who goes
to the supermarket to buy food will know
hardly any of the Plastic Products that
we're sold are just clear wrap they have
labels on they will normally be coming
into contact with food and all that
means that it's not all the same stuff
it's different grades of plastic and you
can't just put all that material
together into one bulk load and then
melt it in recycle it what you'd get if
you did that is unusable terrible
quality plastic so what you need to do
is separate it and to this day the only
way to do that is to have people go
through by hand feel the material with
their fingers sometimes burn it with
fighter to work out what grade of
plastic it is and separate it into
different streams
I had no idea that there's this
incredibly expensive and time consuming
process that has to go into separating
all the different grades
they didn't stay long in the Netherlands
they passed through very quickly and
then they you know went on a German
Motorway and zipped across the country
in the space of sort of 12 to 24 hours
and finally they crossed the border into
Poland and I could see that both digital
trackers although this happened on
different days ended up at precisely the
same spot
this is the Euro key site in Chile
lagora jilanagora is a small a small
town in in West Poland It's relatively
close to the border with Germany
so we we knew we had to go and see where
Tesco's waste was being sent and we knew
the exact location it was going to so I
took a flight to Poland and I teamed up
with my colleague wojcek and uh we we
simply got in the car and drove out to
jalonagora and did a drive-by to to look
at the facility
can see
piles and piles and piles of plastic
this is an exit gate
what we found in jalonagora was a long
industrial building a warehouse it must
have been as long as a football field or
longer they were you know there were
hundreds of tons of material just
sitting out there waiting to be sent
somewhere else
mountains of it
the reason plastic's going there is that
there's a particular British run company
called Euro key
and Yorkie opened this large sorting
facility on the outskirts of shalonagora
and that's where almost all the wastes
that's coming through this Supermarket
system ends up
there are two main reasons why a lot of
plastic waste is exported the first is
that disposing of plastic in a developed
economy like the UK or Germany or the US
is expensive
if you have to landfill for example if
you have to bury the plastic because you
can't use it that costs let's say 100
pounds a ton to do in the UK but the
equivalent cost in Poland is
significantly less it might cost you 20
or 30 pounds a ton to use a landfill
facility in Poland
but there are also um lots of government
incentives that are designed to make
recycling a more attractive proposition
you get credits from the government for
exporting material for recycling
so if your choice is export to Poland or
recycle a material in the UK the
government gives you as much financial
support for exporting as it does for
doing it domestically
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean the most important exercise for
the purposes of this project was to find
out what happened to the bad plastic
because we know that some kinds of
plastic are easy to use now the problem
that the world has to Grapple with is
what happens to the bad plastic what
happens to the stuff that simply isn't
economic to use again
so one of my digital trackers was inside
a lentil puff wrapper like a snack
wrapper I was very keen to see where
that one went and uh I saw it on the
move again about 24 hours after it had
been sorted at shalonagora and it headed
east across Poland to a tiny town called
ponytover and I found out there that it
had been sent to a company called
Stellar pack
Stellar pack are an Eastern European Bag
Maker they make garbage bags essentially
sort of black sacks and things like that
and they have a facility there that can
turn soft plastic back into soft plastic
but they also have a way to dispose of
the plastic they can't use they have an
on-site incinerator which provides heat
and energy for their Factory
Plastics are made from oil
they're essentially fossil fuels so they
burn really well
they burn in a similar way because crude
oil does and so they're great material
for uh incinerating for energy
and in Poland they have a huge cement
industry the cement industry requires a
lot of heat and energy to calcify
Limestone powder and turn it into a
cement they have these gigantic Kilns
that run up to 1 500 degrees Celsius or
2000 degrees Celsius
uh and that has traditionally uh relied
on polish coal for the NG source to to
heat the Kilns
um but in recent years the cement
industry has discovered uh all this
waste material coming into Poland
and
um that it's there's an abundance of it
and that it's very very cheap
and so um it's widespread practice
across Poland now for plastic garbage
and other types of garbage to be
incinerated for energy for the cement
industry
it's actually better than free fuel
because they are paid to take it if
you're a cement maker waste brokers in
Poland will pay you a small sum per ton
to take their waste plastic and
incinerate it in your Kiln so you're
actually making money from your fuel
source it's a fantastic deal you know if
you're in the business of making cement
the tracker inside the Tesco plastic bag
stopped pinging when it arrived in
shalonagora after a few days and I
assumed it had been shredded or
destroyed or trampled on or taken and
then when I got back from Poland I was
surprised to see it its location had
changed and it gave its location as
Southern turkey you know a couple of
hundred kilometers from the Syrian
Border in an industrial estate
not all the plastic that goes to Turkey
is going to end up being dumped or
buried or incinerated illegally there
are good recycling companies in turkey
that have great reputations but
unfortunately turkey has a destination
for Waste has huge problems and a lot of
the plastic that goes to Turkey ends up
being illegally disposed of
the tracker ended up at this industrial
Estates uh a sort of a quite remote one
um
there was no sort of there was no
plastic recycling company nearby that we
could identify so we were confused as to
why it was there and uh you know we we
sent a journalist to the ground
um to drive out and visit this site what
she found outside a warehouse just just
left
in a big pile was tons and tons of waste
from plastic waste from around Europe
um the facility itself wasn't a
recycling facility it was obviously just
left there before it could be moved
somewhere else
you know I don't have any idea what
happened to the the tracker material
that went to that industrial estate in
Turkey
um I can't imagine that it was possible
to recycle it but I don't know what
happened to it after that but we know
that Tesco waste material has been found
in that very area you know for a long
period of time as recently as a few
months ago uh you know I spoke to an
activist who found a Tesco carrier bag
just left by the side of the field in a
smoldering pile of burnt plastic
obviously had been illegally dumped
foreign
[Music]
supermarket chain it's the UK's largest
by far it makes an enormous amount of
profit every year
and it also has this incredible
Logistics infrastructure in place to
make sure it's fresh bread and milk and
meat at all its stores around the UK it
has a network
and if this entity can't properly
dispose of plastic you know what hope is
there for a little cash strapped Town
Council that we want to dispose of our
plastic by the curbside
foreign
Tesco is exporting plastic is because
it's the most cost efficient solution to
their problem
so the reality is despite all the you
know the the nice words and the good
intentions that's still the vast
majority of soft plastic that goes into
the market is either going to be
incinerated or it's going to be buried
foreign
[Music]